[Music]
I after several decades of doing this
work I feel like I know my people fairly
well and most people most white people
are not going to do anything different
most white people that attend my
workshops will say wow that was really
interesting or provocative if they're if
they're open if they're not open they'll
just have their reasons why they have to
reject what I said but even those who
are open to the message if it is not
sustained it won't make much of an
impact you know every I often say when
I'm in front of a group everything out
this outside of this room will compel
you not to see this anymore the forces
are incredibly seductive the forces of
white solidarity the forces of keeping
other white people comfortable the
forces to not see or name any of this
and if you don't put some kind of
structure around yourself to keep you
focused there you're gonna slip right
back into the status quo for so many
white people we think that the answer to
racism is friendliness if you notice
that the evidence that most white people
will give for why they're not racist one
of their top pieces of evidence is I
know people of color
I have friends of color and so if we if
we apply that question you know if we
look at that evidence as a way to
understand the deeper structure of
meaning right it's actually quite
revealing so in order for a claim like
that
I know people of color I have friends of
color in order for a claim like that to
be good evidence of my lack of racism a
racist can't be able to do that
otherwise it's not good evidence right
this is what distinguishes me from a
racist I have people of color in my life
I live in New York City I was in Teach
for America I went to diverse school
these are all the claims that white
people will make for their lack of
racism well that must mean a racist can
livens in New York City could not know
or speak to or be friendly to people of
color could not be in the Peace Corps
etc and I'm hoping you can see right now
how ridiculous that evidence is because
even an avowed racist can do all of
those things so most white people
believe that niceness is all it takes
and the the status quo of our society is
the reproduction of racial inequality
that's what it does it's a default of
all of our institutions our norms and
our policies it's what our society does
it's what it's always done our outcomes
are not improving by many measures our
outcomes of racial disparity are
increasing right and all this system
needs to keep on keeping on reproducing
racial inequality with whites benefiting
from it is for white people just to be
really nice be really nice go ahead
smile at your co-workers of color go to
lunch on occasion and do nothing else
and you will uphold that system because
niceness is not courageous niceness is
not anti racism niceness will not get
racism on the table and it will not keep
it on the table when everyone wants it
off the table I suppose it's better than
not being nice but it takes strategic
intentional anti-racist action it is a
lifelong process that I will never be
finished from the mainstream definition
of a racist is an individual always an
individual not a system who consciously
does not like people based on race must
be conscious and intentionally seeks to
be mean to them must be intentional and
that definition I believe is the root of
virtually all white defensive Mis on
this topic it makes it virtually
impossible to talk to the average white
person about the inevitable absorption
of a racist worldview that we get from
living in a society in which racism is
the foundation and the bedrock and I'm
going to use a term here that I
understand is charged and that's
white supremacy I'm very comfortable
with the term yes it includes extremists
we might think of as white nationalists
or neo-nazis it also is a highly
descriptive sociological term for the
water we swim it for the society we live
in a society that holds white people up
as the human ideal as the norm for
humanity and everyone else as a
particular kind of human and a deficient
one right so I live in a society that
from the time I open my eyes in myriad
ways both implicit and explicit has
conveyed to me that I am inherently
superior because I'm white the research
shows that all children by age 3 to 4
understand it's better to be white
all children me I got that message you
got that message everyone gets it you
can't miss it and it's not isolated it's
not singular it's not depending on any
one person
it's relentlessly circulating and so
internalized superiority is another
great challenge or barrier for white
people wanting to push through this or
address this we can talk about
individualism and how that functions and
universalism and white solidarity but I
think the hardest one for us to face is
internalized superiority and yet when
you accept that you you got that message
you couldn't help it you can then get to
work trying to challenge that message
rather than inadvertently protect it
through your defensive nasaan your
refusal to engage with it and so we
simply can't get where we need to go
from the current paradigm that says only
mean intentional individuals could ever
perpetrate or participate in racism when
you change your paradigm it's so
transformative and liberating right so
what we need to do is think very
differently about what racism is to
understand that while I would never use
the n-word my
racial illiteracy was not benign right
my inability to think critically and
deeply about racism before I engaged in
this work actually ended up creating a
hostile climate for the people of color
in my life right my defensive
nastanovich I'd to talk to me about
unaware assumptions I may be making or
an unintentional harm I may be
perpetrating I would lash back and
refuse that right and that that causes
harm right so I think I try to be a
little less white I'm really clear that
I am NOT going to be free of my
conditioning in in racism is not going
to end in my lifetime the question I
asked myself how is the question I asked
myself is how do I do a little less harm
and how do I know right
am I in any given moment behaving in
anti-racist ways not I'm already done
I'm never racist right not I'm a
terrible person I'm always racist in any
given moment how am i doing and how do I
know and that keeps me humble
and it keeps me accountable right so for
me to do less harm is no small thing
because it could literally be one more
hour on a person to colors life who
didn't have to take home my nonsense and
agonize all night long whether it was
worth it to talk to me or they should
just suck it up yet again unless they
risk my lashing out in defensive nasubi
less white is to be less oppressive
racially to be less arrogant to be less
certain to be thus
defensive to be less ignorant quite
frankly to be more humble to listen to
believe to break with apathy to break
with white solidarity it's not easy it's
a lifelong process but
nothing is more rewarding
[Music]
you